Introduction
Everyone knows that Hollywood bends the rules
of reality to bring stories to the big screen.
Even movies based on true events fudge things
up a bit.
It’s called artistic license, and many viewers
accept it as part of the film industry.
The problem is when the “truths” movies
present are so prevalent, they become accepted
as actual fact.
People have a misconstrued vision of how society
operates because of movies, and they may be
surprised to learn how much films get wrong.
Here are 10 movie myths you probably still
believe.
Laser Blasts Are Visible
A staple of any sci-fi film, laser guns are
the go-to weapons for the characters.
They look cool and don’t require ammunition
reloads, but there’s one issue.
The laser blasts are visible.
If laser guns were every created in the real-world,
people wouldn’t be able to see the blasts.
Beams need something to reflect on to be seen.
In addition, invisible laser blasts would
be more powerful, since visible beams scatter
photons, making it less potent.
This would certainly make all the fun Star
Wars dogfights a little less exciting.
Thankfully, it’s simply science fiction.
Cops Have to Read Miranda Rights
If you’ve seen any cop TV show or film,
chances are you’re familiar with the Miranda
rights.
Beginning with the famous line “You have
the right to remain silent,” police officers
say this upon arresting a suspect before bringing
them in.
If they forget to read the rights – as shown
in 21 Jump Street – the criminal can go
free on a technicality.
But that’s not how it works.
The Miranda rights are only for people about
to be interrogated by authorities and are
not required when someone gets arrested.
This way, perpetrators can’t claim the officer
didn’t read the rights and exploit a loophole.
They’re still in police custody.
The Insanity Defense Works
Frequently, when a character commits a murder
in a movie, their lawyer will attempt to prove
insanity so the alleged criminal gets off
free.
As long as one of your multiple personalities
did it, it’s OK, right?
Wrong.
The insanity defense is rarely used, only
in less than one percent of all cases.
Even then, it’s successful less than 25
percent of the time.
There are also states that don’t even allow
that defense to be heard.
Considering a criminal can prove insanity,
they’re not “free” per say.
They have to stay at a mental institution
until the doctors deem them fit to return
to society.
That could be twice as long as a jail sentence.
Explosions Aren’t a Big Deal
As the Lonely Island once told us, cool guys
don’t look at explosions.
Turns out, they wouldn’t survive any, either.
Several action movies showcase jaw-dropping
explosions that shatter just about everything
in its path – except the main protagonist.
The hero will typically make a dashing escape
by using the explosion as a means to propel
him through the air.
Unfortunately, should John McClane try his
antics in real life, his body would be torn
to pieces by the shockwave.
Explosions go through things, which would
obviously kill somebody and end a film franchise
quicker than any villain could dream.
Airplanes Are Easy to Start
Whenever the heroes need to make a quick getaway,
there’s always an empty aircraft for them
to use.
All it takes is the flip of a couple of switches,
and the plane can take off.
If only it were that simple.
Being a pilot isn’t the same as driving
a standard car, and there’s typically a
huge checklist of things to go through before
flying a vehicle.
A 747 jet requires 123 items before going
off the ground, and the helicopter from The
A-Team has a 9-page list.
In real life, even fighter jets take 15 minutes
to take off when they’re called into action
in an emergency, so Hollywood needs to find
a new way to get heroes out of a jam.
Tracing Calls Take a Long Time
In a game of cat-and-mouse, the villain may
call the hero to taunt him or her, and there’s
a mad dash to trace the call and track down
the evildoer’s location.
When the good guys get oh so close to completing
the task, the villain hangs up, smug in victory.
But if movies were following real world practices,
they’d find the baddies in no time.
Police usually know where you are as soon
as you call them, and the FCC requires wireless
networks to have location-tracking technology.
They only time this would work is if the villain
was using a stolen or prepaid phone, and it
still wouldn’t take a minute to find.
Mid-Budget Movies Are Easy to Green Light
Movies are a business driven by profits, so
one would think that smaller budgeted projects
would be welcomed by executives looking to
make a quick buck.
That isn’t the case.
As you may have noticed, franchises are the
dominant form of film these days, with the
studios banking on well-known intellectual
properties to drive their release slates.
If a movie isn’t a huge tentpole based on
something, it’s harder to get approved.
Mark Wahlberg spent years developing the boxing
drama The Fighter, which went on to be an
awards player.
It doesn’t matter how great a film can be,
it needs to be recognizable or it could never
be made.
Hacking is Only Done By Criminals
There’s no denying that hacking is illegal
and can lead to serious consequences.
Just ask Sony.
Still, it isn’t something that’s exclusively
done by criminals looking for a way to get
ahead.
Hacking is actually a legitimate career, and
professional ones are usually hired by companies
to look into their systems for weak spots.
These are typically normal, everyday people
just trying to make a living and have no malicious
intent when they hack into servers.
Finding vulnerabilities can lead to a substantial
payday, so this really doesn’t sound so
bad after all.
T-Rex Can’t See Things That Don’t Move
When the t-rex breaks out of its Jurassic
Park paddock, Alan Grant tells Lex that the
dinosaur can’t see them if they don’t
move.
Sure enough, the t-rex is right in front of
his prey but doesn’t know it.
Studies have shown that Grant and the kids
would have been a tasty meal for a real-world
t-rex, whose eyesight rivaled that of a hawk
or eagle.
In the novel, this trait was explained by
the amphibian DNA used to fill in the genetic
gaps impacted the eyes, but the film makes
no mention of it.
It’s a plot hole that bothered scientists,
but general audiences didn’t seem to care.
Instant Communication Is Possible Across Great
Distances
Sci-fi movies love to show people communicating
with each other, even when they’re on completely
different planets.
Their messages get across instantly, and there’s
typically no delay.
They have a conversation as if they were in
the same room.
If someone tried this in the real world, they’d
be disappointed.
The average time lag for a message from Earth
to Mars can be almost 21 minutes, with another
21 added for a reply.
That certainly paints Mark Watney’s plight
in a new light.
Thankfully, his communications system in The
Martian seemed to be more advanced.
Those are our picks for movie myths you still
believe.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorites?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos!